jean millaire bonsoir vous venez de ses
grâces et d'éditeurs français qui vient
de faire paraître la traduction de vote
de vos mémoires votre autobiographie le
titre au fil du temps une vie dont vos
éditions grasset traduit de l'américain
par dominique ruelle et marie caroline
aubert c'est un gros livre de 500 pages
tout à fait passionnant mais on va en
parler alors vous ne parlez pas très
bien le français mais je vais quand même
vous demander quand même de répondre en
français ma première question parce qu'à
un certain moment dans le livre on dit
que vous parler un français scolaire est
ce à dire que vous avez appris le
français à l'école ou à l'université
oui l'école highco oui c'est un avant
des collèges
mais c'était il ya longtemps je parle
français comme mon enfant mauvais
exemple pour les autres enfants mais
vous lisez mieux le français que vous ne
parlez donc vous avez pu lire un peu là
je manque de pratique a parlé rester
longtemps en france et vous paraît très
bien je vous présente les les deux
invités avec readsoft qui vous allez
parler il y a donc françois périer qui
remporte un triomphe au théâtre avec une
de vos pièces mort d'un commis voyageur
qui a été représenté à l'odéon qui est
maintenant en province philippe labro
qui connaît très bien la mairie qui les
journalistes directeur de rtl
il est aussi cinéaste et romancier et
puis à côté de vos liens chez une chaise
vide un fauteuil vide
il sera occupé tout à l'heure par
monsieur andré brink est un écrivain à
sud africain qui était de passage à
paris
et comme vous ne vous connaissez pas
l'un l'autre j'ai pensé que c'était une
bonne occasion de vous faire rencontrer
donc il viendra à tout à l'heure un
quart d'heure vingt minutes de la fin de
l'émission
une question alors maintenant j'aimerais
qu'on entend d'ailleurs une traduction
simultanée les jouets qu'on entend de
votre voix parlant bien l'américain je
demanderai donc à philippe labro de
traduire c'est la réponse à cette
première question vous dit que le succès
vous êtes toujours donner un sentiment
de culpabilité pourquoi la bible arthur
muller pense que la culpabilité en
question vient du fait que il a commencé
dans la vie on travaille entre ses mains
comme ouvrier en réalité et que par
conséquent lorsqu'il a quitté le monde
du travail le monde des prolétaires et a
toujours eu l'impression d'abandonner
laissé derrière lui ça va être une
communauté c'était pour ça qu'il ya
cette mauvaise conscience et il dit
aussi que la célébrité c'est une autre
forme de la solitude mais c'est quand
même une solitude agréable et ce prix on
est toujours quelque chose ne facilite
pas les choses
enfin beaucoup d'entre eux cherchent à
obtenir quelque chose en tout cas bien
alors monsieur miller nous allons jouer
une sorte de pièce de théâtre impromptue
en quatre actes le premier acte ce sera
le dramaturge l'homme de théâtre
arthur miller le deuxième acte sera
l'homme dans la cité c'est à dire
l'intellectuel engagé le troisième acte
s'intitulera le mari de marilyn monroe
ou bien marilyn monroe épouse de arthur
muller et enfin le quatrième axe ce sera
votre rencontre avec andré brink sur ce
plateau d' apostrophes un jeu commence
le premier acte c'est donc le l'homme de
théâtre
vous vous rappelez que vous êtes allé
pour la première fois au théâtre à l'âge
de 8 ans mais est ce que vous vous
rappelez la pièce que vous avez lu
litres
et que c'est l'autre qui étaient à bord
du navire était à la recherche d'un
pianiste
le suspect est formidable c'est que
j'avais donc une bombe à bord du navire
et de navires attendent head on et les
gens ne savaient pas où elles étaient
donc on essayer justement de préciser où
se trouvait là et j'étais très très très
impressionné en temps quand un détail
intéressant pour tous les apprentis
auteur dramatique en france c'est que
pendant dizaine d'années vous avez
essuyé des refus de la plupart des
directeurs de théâtres des producteurs
de théâtre ça ne vous a pas découragé et
découragés mais pensait que c'était moi
ce métier je devais en faire partie
je l'adoré vous êtes envisagerez faire
autre chose c'est pourquoi je me suis né
et j'ai gagné ma vie en écrivant des
scénarios pour la radio je ne déteste et
cela me permet de gagner de quoi
subsister parce que ça aussi il faut
bien manger mais j'ai décidé d'écrire
une pièce absolue chacun des instants
serait tout à fait clair pour moi
c'était ils étaient tous mes fils
lorsque j'ai fini décret cette pièce
tout le monde voulait la mettre en scène
et ça a été votre premier succès et vous
disiez d'ailleurs quand vous vous dites
dans le livre d'ailleurs que vous ai dit
c'est ma dernière chance c'est de ça
réussit pas cette fois j'abandonnerai
loin de rester crise a tourné autour de
théâtre j'ai consacré deux années de
travail à cette pièce est ce que
d'entrée vous considériez que l'art est
donc le théâtre doit servir à je dirais
du quai la société transformer la
société
randy où j'ai mûri dans les années 30
et à cette époque révolutionnaire a été
transformée bouleversé et new york était
une ville où ça se passait spéciale donc
on s'en fiche sur les mondes pour être
changée par ce qui se passait sur les
planches et c'était une conviction que
je partageais résoudre je pense que
c'était l'apogée du théâtre à l'époque
c'était juste avant d'hitler et la
grande guerre et la deuxième guerre mais
c'est toujours votre conviction d'homme
de théâtre que le théâtre doit servir à
transformer la société
je veux quoi comment le vit prendre mais
je veux croire que c'est possible
une chose est tout à fait étonnante
c'est que on s'aperçoit que lorsque vous
allez écrire une pièce lorsque vous avez
choisi le sujet vous allez faire une
enquête sur le terrain comme un reporter
mes pièces à gourette une signification
pour les gens qui ont je veux qu'ils se
disent oui ça ça correspond à la réalité
nancy il faut vérifier certains frais et
bien que je veille à bien les vérifier
mais je donne un exemple pour écrire vu
du pont vous avez fait une véritable
enquête sur les docks et sur toutes les
les gangsters dans les syndicats
américains vous avez donc fait vraiment
une enquête sur le terrain et parfois
même dangereuse
on le fait parce que les auteurs j'étais
si un débardeur voyez ma pièce il devait
penser voilà ça c'est la vérité
oui c'est ça au fond le final en asie ne
s'est pas seulement que arthur miller
vous avez envie que les ouvriers le long
des quais dit c'est la vérité il ya une
phrase très importante selon moi sur son
art de tra mature c'est quand il dit
très tôt dans le livre que au fond toute
sa vie s'est imposé une règle je sais
que jamais une femme aux cheveux
décolorés
il est très innocemment vulgaire mais
tendres et aimantes ne soit déçu par une
de ses pièces
j'étais aussi définition qui mérite une
explication d'ailleurs parce qu'on
pourrait la prendre de façon un peu
méprisante vis-à-vis du public
je crois plutôt qu'au contraire elle
signifie que vous vouliez que l'homme
moyen à la femme moyenne américaine
accepter un euro pièce tout de suite
l'un des points faibles de notre c'est
que adam braz
le public est donc scellé atomisé il y à
un agent mecs tapie qui ne se mélangent
pas headrick et on constate qu'il ya des
techniques qui se construit dans la
durée que je grandirai pas du théâtre
grec shakespearien eh bien c'est la
société et est amalgamé il fallait que
shakespeare se passe comprendre non
seulement aux gens très accrue mais
également un moyen moins instruits il
faut ajouter qu'en 4 et bien les pièces
de shakespeare sont toujours clair
compréhensible et magnifique pour
beaucoup de gens alors je me tourne
maintenant vers l'homme de théâtre
qu'est françois périer et
et vous jouez donc actuellement mort
d'un commis voyageur et le hasard a bien
fait les choses parce que vous ne jouez
pas soir vraiment merci le hasard est ce
que alors vous avez donc lu ce livre est
ce que vous avez appris des choses à la
fois sur arthur miller ou sur le mort
d'un commis voyageur parce qu'il en
parle beaucoup dans son livre que vous
ne saviez pas je ne connaissais que
l'auteur par ses oeuvres et j'ai eu
l'occasion de le rencontrer l'homme et
de découvrir l'homme par par cet écrit
extraordinaire qui m'a d'ailleurs
absolument fasciné parce que c'est
précis c'est clair c'est un homme on a
l'impression qu'ils voient toujours
juste qu'ils ne se trompent pas et
j'espère que ça ne choquera pas j'ai eu
l'occasion d'avoir des rapports très
étroits avec sartre et j'ai retrouvé un
homme du même genre alors qu'ils n'ont
rien de commun
mais des gens aussi clair aux erreurs et
si oui quand
rigoureux et qui ont une acuité
extraordinaire et ça c'est très très
important au théâtre et en effet je
partage tout à fait le point de vue d'
arthur muller il faut absolument que
tous les publics comprennent et il ne
faut pas qu'il y ait plusieurs publics
il n'ya qu'un public hier sur mort d'un
commis voyageur vous avez vu que sont
des personnages qu'il a connues compris
même des gens de sa famille qui lui ont
servi à weedon rôle que vous jouez il
détailla et les d'ailleurs dans dans
dans le livre que chaque fois qu'il a
parlé de cette pièce ou que des gens ont
vu cette pièce les gens dit ah mais mon
père et se sont mis à lui parler de leur
père et moi le jour où j'ai lu
l'adaptation de jean claude grumberg ses
dix balles
il faut que je joue cette pièce parce
que mon père était représente 30
commerces et je veux absolument
je veux absolument jouer cette pièce
parce que je retrouvais dans le sens où
il est lohman des caractéristiques de
mon père alors le masne vous raconter
comment vous allez trouver ce nom willy
loman qui est donc le rôle que vous
jouez avec les enfants le mal les deux
fils lohman c'est un mot qui vous
revient
bien d'un film vous rappelez vous voulez
vous raconter ça nombre que je voulais
dire lohman l'homme dont le statut est
bas de nférieure là on devait tenir et
dont le nom vient du fait des il devient
détective qui s'appelait complètement
parce que j'avais et donc c'est ça qui
est monsieur hurlé par notre détective
qui épris de terrain rappelle l'omct a
romainville mur là et ensuite les
lumières ses affres épouvantable et
ensuite ses ventes il hésite à le gagner
et il est là au téléphone j'avais
complètement oublié cela lorsque j'ai
revu ce que j'ai été absolument avéré de
voir que j'avais emprunté ce film se
livrent à ce film de fritz lang
alors je vais vous faire je pense une
bonne surprise arthur muller vous n'avez
encore je pas vu françois périer jouant
la pièce pour la commune voyageurs je
vous en présenter un extrait je signale
que donc elle a été créée au théâtre de
l'odéon dans une adaptation de jean
claude grumberg et dans une mise en
scène de marcel bluwal et dans la scène
qu'on va voir c'est françois périer
willy loman avec claude winter qui joue
linda lohman son épouse voici donc un
extrait de mort d'un commis voyageur il
faut que tu leur parles tu dois te dire
quelque chose sur dur à new york du zéro
pour véro mois moi je suis la nouvelle
angleterre sans moi il peut y perdre la
région
il faut que télégraphie à portland j'ai
rendez vous demain matin à la première
heure chez braun et morrison pourquoi tu
passerais pas demain matin voir howard
au bureau pour lui dire une fois pour
toutes qui doit te donner une carte sur
new york plus trop conciliant si franck
wagner était encore de
monde c'est moi qui serai directeur des
ventes ici ce type là c'était réellement
quelqu'un mais son fils cet award
qu'est-ce qui connaît qu'est-ce qui
connaît c'est moi qui ai défricher la
nouvelle angleterre pour lawanya
compagnie fram planté les drapeaux sur
sa carte à chaque nouvelle vie qui
tombaient il me demandait mais où es tu
dénicher site web du déni 16 clients
will et où es tu n'es ni chaise pliante
où se trouve cette [ __ ] de ville
la voir ou revoir demain eddie lui tout
ça et comment j'ai envie d'un morceau
j'en en ont fait coucher et toi je les
enfants sont rentrés wii sont couchés
appui a sorti son frère avec des filles
c'était un tel bonheur se raser tous les
deux l'un après l'autre
toute la maison sont encore le cerveau
voilà trim comme un homme toute ta vie
péta maison traite après treize mois
après mois et quand enfin elle est bien
à toi mais y'a plus personne pour 8,2
dans plus personne voilà et l'or alors
que miley raconte une anecdote qui est
étonnant parce qu'il dit qu'ils se sont
théâtre doit transformer la société
raconte que à la première de la pièce il
y avait le directeur d'un grand magasin
d'une chaîne de grands magasins qui a vu
la pièce il a donné l'ordre à son chef
de personnel de ne jamais licencier
quelqu'un pour parce qu'il est vieux on
va vous rappeler ceci ya aussi un
programme game boy game room and the
c'était un très très gros une grande
surface à new york son choix et je suis
allée comme instruction personne ne se
réunissant fier à nouveau parce qu'il
avait dépassé la limite d'âge
françois périer vous avez alors une
admiration commune c'est pour louis
jouvet car vous avez remarqué
effectivement arthur miller évoque une
représentation de ondine
a paris quand il est passé 48 ans 45
et oui la vue je vais et il a compris là
il a senti le lien sans comprendre
très clairement la langue et il a senti
le lien entre l'acteur et le public et
qui dans le cas de jouer était tout à
fait fascinant émerveillé s attend à
l'époque ses copains jean cau était
glaciale et les journal 3,6 il raconte
ses valeurs par dessus et geniki lui
même dès ce moment sur kill débat voire
très très froid lorsqu'il parlait
c'était miraculeux
parce que je crois complètement saoul
vais oublier s'est spécialisé sur moi
c'est ça le théâtre ce que le tien tu es
censé réaliser alors peut-être votre
pièce la plus jouée dans le monde entier
sait les sorcières de salem
évidemment c'est une pièce contre
l'intolérance et vous dites que lorsque
on la joue dans un pays c'est que
générallement où le pays va vivre des
jours difficiles où il vient de vivre
des jours difficiles mais pas en france
en france quand elle était représentée
il n'y avait pas deux alors vous avez
assisté la représentation en france avec
montand signoret on ne m'a pas accordé
de passeport pour me rendre en france
retiré en fait c'est département d'état
qui pendant cinq ans est interdit de
quitter le territoire américain
je comprends très bien le sort des gens
mariage ce genre de leu leu vraiment
rouleau a tiré un film de votre pièce
les sorcières de salem et vous fait et
c'est sartre qui en a fait l'adaptation
bouteflika mais vous critiquez
l'adaptation qu'en a fait ça
gilles a créé une opposition entre les
riches et les pauvres de prison une
analyse est en réalité wa salam certains
bourgeois les plus riches vont tester
rendu ainsi que des pauvres donc c'est
un peu un contact avec deuxième saut
muse et c'est que il a créé communauté
catholique n'avait un crucifix sur le
musée ne pouvait pas imaginer la
religion catholique
je m'en suis surtout pria cela est donc
cette cette pièce film contre
l'intolérance nous amène au deuxième
acte de cette émission c'est à dire
arthur miller l'homme dans la cité
l'intellectuel engagé alors je me dis là
je me tourne vers vous philippe labro
d'abord votre sentiment sur le libre
adam dunn je vais le j'éprouve la même
admiration et le met la même fascination
françois périer parce que c'est tout
idem et unique mais la vie de arthur
muller est particulièrement riche
foisonnante et la façon dont cette
biographie est construite et n'est pas
construit ses terres cette façon de
faire revenir le passé il faut qu'on
passe à vis de a jusqu'à z de façon
chronologique et des espèces de retour
en avant de retour en arrière s'est
remarquablement fait un peu d'ailleurs
comme il construit ses pièces connues
comme mort d'un commis voyageur avec
l'utilisation au fond si matt aut
graphique de ce qu'on appelle le flash
back dont tout le monde connaît
maintenant la technique mais c'est pas
seulement la technique c'est qu'il ya
une vie extraordinaire rien humour
extraordinaire il ya des scènes
absolument sans dire pendant l'enfance
en particulier la description du
grand-père qui se sert de son lit de
mort pour les cogner sur un rabbin
l'arrière quand tu joues l'arrière grand
père grand père et suscite pour aller
récupérer des bijoux que le faucher le
rabbin ce que personne ne croit mais lui
sait très bien que le rabais les a
fauchés il ya des moments d'une drôlerie
folle des moments aussi la bénédiction
pour pas ce qui les pousse son premier
mariage une catholique et la dispense
huit jours passés dans un endroit trans
m'ennuyer de middle west avec des
parents catholiques
bon genre et voilà ce juif de brooklyn
qui est là à essayer de gagner une
respectabilité qu'il n'y aura jamais et
finalement c'est lui quand même 10 ans
porte morceau il y à aussi bien sûr
toutes ces rencontres parce que celui
vraie étude est une espèce de traversée
du demi-siècle et des portraits pas
seulement américains des portraits de
gens que nous connaissons tous au plus
nous croyons tous connaître steinbeck
il ya 15 ans si la tra kennedy lucchi
lucciano une rencontre looking sicile
avec lucky luciano par hasard dans un
restaurant ou en plus müller fait preuve
d'ailleurs ciblé mois le regret que j'ai
en liant ce bouquin c'est que n'est pas
écrit plus de romans parce que je trouve
qu'il a une verve et un talent et un
regard de romancier prodigieux il
explique comment luciano comme tous les
hommes d'ailleurs les deux profils il
avait un profil qui ressemble plutôt à
une artiste ou d'un ou des représentants
de commerce et puis l'avait un profil de
tueur et comment en quelques lignes
arthur miller nous décrit ça il ya aussi
pardon mais on ne peut pas s'empêcher de
le citer une ouverture d'un chapitre sur
hollywood en dix lignes il va faire une
description à travers les parfums et les
odeurs moi je considère c'est très
important pour un romancier c'est
d'essayer d'écrire un endroit une époque
d'un moment de sa vie à travers des
odeurs et c'est vrai qu hollywood a une
odeur particulière que nous avons tous
connu au lit ou tous ceux qui ont connu
ude ont essayé de la définir il lui est
arrivé et je peux vous dire que c'est
difficile qu'un mélange de plastique
d'essence dont deux femmes un peu bon
marché c'est remarquable donc d'abord
grande écriture est très bien traduite
il faut le dire remarquablement traduit
ensuite une vie fascinante avec des
moments très très exceptionnelle
et puis je crois aussi au jour demain ça
va ça va le compte à ok
vous pouvez continuer je suis
complètement satisfait la bombe je suis
complètement sincère je pense que tous
les gens qui diront votre livre
prouveront la même attraction le même
intérêt d'autant plus que vous ne vous
fait pas de cadeau dit les choses c'est
comme alors revenons maintenant à metz
il avait cru à l'intellectuel engagé bas
l'intellectuel engagé il il explique
comment il est né au fond dans ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque une culture anti
fasciste n'est ce pas arthur miller est
ce qu'on peut appeler le représentant
type de la gauche américaine de la
grande époque dans l'époque des hommes
de gauche américain je ne sais pas s'il
y en a encore aujourd'hui et il explique
comment à travers la crise bien su à
travers les années 30 et à travers une
rencontre fortuite
un jour dans la rue d'un jeune étudiant
sur un vélo que lui expliquer que un
jour nouveau que des lendemains
chantants allait apparaître
comment il a fini par croire à tout cela
et comment il s'est battu contre
l'intolérance contre le f milliard
contre le maccarthysme canton c'était
pas terrible des états unis monde a
oublié et qui faisait qu'on enlevait son
passeport à quelqu'un qui simplement
n'était pas d'accord avec l'idéologie
dominante
les listes rouges tout ce qui s'est
passé leurs questions
alors question d'abord c'est une
question sur votre regard aujourd'hui
parce que vous avez encore le regard de
l'enfance mais aussi celle d'un che âge
chinois il me semble parfois vous avez
mis de côté les idéologies de côté vos
combats et même vos engagements
vous les voyez pas mais vous les
regardez avec une ironie extraordinaire
vous dites à moment donné quand on on
sait qu'on est arrivé à un certain âge
de la vie quand on tousse qu'on regarde
on le regarde avec dérision et bien
écoutez je regarde les choses avec une
certaine patience les choses se produire
une fois deux fois se reproduit suis né
où cela est bien ça doit quand même la
muse et ce que nous ne cessons de
réparer ma journée
différent de ce qu'il était parrainé le
monde a changé le monde générale en tout
cas en ce qui me concerne je crois que
l'occident est beaucoup mieux
ou bien meilleure situation il est passé
il ya une explosion des classiques en la
sienne au plan ce que nous appelons
tiers montrer plus personne ne sait quoi
faire y compris des lattes qui sont au
beau milieu de la mêlée et c'est ça la
question des sports de façon aiguë donc
il s'agit de savoir maintenant comment
il va faire évoluer et je ne serai pas
en quelques minutes je vous dirais que
je crois que aujourd'hui le siège se
trouve en dépit de ses problèmes dans
une situation bien meilleur qu'il ne l'a
été par le passé
oui mais vous avez cru au marxisme vous
n'y croyez plus vous semblait n'avoir
jamais cru croire aux pour capitalisme
donc aujourd'hui vous ne croyez ni au
marxisme et au capitalisme en quoi
croyez vous je crois qu'il faut a
fondamentalement il ya donc une protégée
la démo ce alors peu importe qu'elle
soit plus ou moins parce que je crois
que je l'aurais sont différents il
s'agit du capitaine sociale inss ce qui
est important trois endroits dans
certains pays levaï habitera 10 max ou
et d'excellents résultats dont sophie
comme par exemple eh bien je crois que
le fait de pencher vers le socialisme 7g
résultat essentiel c'est la défense des
droits humains à turny l'air est ce que
dans les années 50
sartre et camus ont eu une influence sur
les intellectuels américains de gauche à
5 fois et macho
parce que à l'époque ils étaient les
chefs de chantier
ils étaient les paroles d'un nouvel
humanisme employés après la terrible
calamité que attirer l'attention sur la
responsabilité individuelle des châteaux
enrichir les grands systèmes crash qui
pouvait peut-être walid mais qu'il
écrase et l'individu et je crois que
c'était une merveilleuse contribution de
leur part
il ya dans le livre d'arthur miller des
phrases et des opinions et des
descriptions très dur très dur elle sur
les hommes politiques
vous semblez les assimiler des acteurs
parfois sinistre il ya une description
en quelques lignes du premier débat
télévisé entre kennedy et nixon moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est que ça il ya un
manque total de charité pas plus pour
nixon toute l'énergie dont pourtant
qu'elle ai dit vous auriez pu être un d
un des défenseurs et puis quelques pages
plus loin ces régates en prend plein la
figure aussi plaint son compte et il
semble que vous assimile y est au fond
les hommes politiques d'aujourd'hui à
des saltimbanques réponse d'un tube à la
télévision surfer sur ainsi accentuer
l'aspect superficiel
les hommes politiques ont toujours été
des communes un des acteurs toujours été
parce qu'il va bien je fasse plaisir
le produit une impression dans le passé
c'était simplement une personne
il est probable que c'est intéressant
quoi devenir leader même si même si elle
n'a pas dit aux gens ils souhaitent être
ici aussi ne soit pas trop
peu après mme lincoln était un homme qui
est quand même très beau à regarder il
avait une voix qui elle est mal passée
par rapport à l'autre donc élu à notre
époque en dépit de son génie parce que
tout simplement il avait il y avait
mauvais apparence il faut parler il faut
il ya un an qu'il faut prononcer c'est
celui d'elia kazan grand grand metteur
en scène de théâtre et de cinéma qui a
été longtemps votre ami et avec qui vous
vous êtes fâché c'est un c'est une
grande douleur dans votre mémoire elia
kazan ou pas été lésés car nous étions
très affecté aux jeunes et chez nous
cela dit qu' il y avait une très
important à savoir thé résistance
l'hystérie se tenir nous abstenons nous
allions tous être rallié dépit a
l'impression qu'il avait d'avoir
restauré porte acceptait son poignet je
crois que brad et je préfère extrêmement
douloureux pour moi de passer d'accord
avec la fin tout en ayant de la section
pour cette personne et c'est tout à fait
ce qui s'est produit pour moi avec mes
amis kazan oui m'enfin si vous lui
reprochez plus si vous a trahi il a
témoigné devant la commission des
antilles desmenez anti américaine et ils
courent vous considérez qu'il a été au
fond un lâche qui là qu'il a donné tout
le monde sait ça que vous lui reprochez
à marseille
également et au saut qu'il voulait
tellement qu'ils ont oublié d'en vouloir
au comité qu'artiste un symbole c'était
trop passifs alors qu'en réalité il
était également
il était peut-être plus élevé faut-il
qu'un artiste lui devienne un héros aux
états unis lorsque lorsqu'on exige qu'il
y ait des héros c'est peut-être un peu
la fin du monde mais vous l'avez revu
depuis parce que c'est laid ya trente
ans maintenant
oui je les revues mais je n'ai pas vu
pendant quelques années bien 161 une
autre pièce ensemble 61 et là il a dû
théâtre c'est à dire on va essayer de
faire un théâtre grand public 16 comme
la comédie française et où le fait en
angleterre à bordeaux n'est pas vraiment
où il était à la tête de ce grand
peintre moins chaud et oguchi l'homme le
plus bas qualifiés pour cette fonction
c'était et donc je voulais faire partie
de ce théâtre fin du deuxième acte
j'aurais voulu lire un portrait de
malraux qu absolument en ruine qui est
absolument inouïe abonde troisième acte
le mari de marilyn monroe ou marilyn
monroe épouse de l'arthur miley je
voudrais que françois périer nous lisent
quelques lignes c'est l'un des nombreux
porte est absolument magnifique de de
marilyn
françois elle était alors pour moi une
sorte de lumière tourbillonnante tout à
la fois un paradoxe est un mystère dur
comme une fille des rues par moment puis
porté par une sensibilité lyrique et
poétique comme peu de gens en conserve
après leur adolescence parfois elle
semblait considérer tous les hommes
comme des petits garçons des enfants
avec des besoins immédiats que la nature
l'avait chargé de satisfaire mais dans
le même temps la partie adulte en elle
se tenait à l'égard et observait le jeu
les hommes n'étaient que désir impérieux
est en quelque sorte sacré il lui
arrivait de raconter comment au cours
d'une soirée deux hommes l'avaient
maintenus de force et avait tenté en
vain heureusement de la violer mais la
véracité du récit avait moins
d'importance que la distance étrange
avec laquelle elle l'aura portait en fin
de compte quelque chose de l'ordre du
divin émerger de cette désincarnation
elle était complètement incapable de
condamner de juger même des gens qui lui
avait fait du mal et être auprès d'elle
c'était être acceptée entrez dans une
zone lumineuse et sanctifiant tu après
avoir quitté une vie où le soupçon
régnait en maître
elle n'avait aucun sens commun mais ce
qu'elle avait été plus à créer une
vision profonde elle seule avait
vraiment conscience les êtres humains
n'étaient que désire et blessures
ce qu'elle voulait le plus n'étaient pas
jugés mais être reconnu par une
profession cruel et par des hommes qui
ne voyaient en elle que la perfection de
la beauté est pas l'humanité
elle était moitié rennes moitié enfants
abandonnés parfois agenouillé devant son
propre corps parfois désespérés à cause
de lui
voilà alors on va on va maintenant faire
présenté des photographies la bande
titre de comme on dit dans le jargon des
photographies de marilyn monroe avec
arthur muller et je vais répondre à
cette question
vous dites un moment où la rencontre et
à haut niveau vous êtes mariés vous avez
des enfants vous dites je luttais pour
conserver mon mariage et ma famille
intacte pourquoi marine landrot at elle
été la plus forte et et est-ce que c'est
seulement sa beauté qui vous a obligé à
changer d'une manière brutale le cours
de votre vie et mon mariage était déjà
en train de pêcher fac d'une conjugaison
de facteurs si vous faites qu'elles
devraient représenter de la durée des
sites et l'authenticité en tant qu'être
agissait comme aoste elle semblait être
se prêter à vos contradictions les plus
violentes sans chercher à les aplanir
mais vous lui avez dit au début de votre
votre liaison tué la femme la plus
triste que j'aie jamais rencontré
et curieusement on pourrait penser
qu'elle allait être qu'elle allait
mettre désappointé et vous réponds tu es
le seul homme qui met jamais dit cela et
on est contente c'est curieux ok
qu'ils devaient combattre à forte
pression et qu'elle avait vraiment fait
honneur était une façon d'échapper à sa
tristesse elle convainc t tauri jo
pesanteur que représentait la tristesse
en manipulant de la joie rêve c'était sa
façon
mais arthur miller elle a pris plus de
risque en vous épousant que vous en
l'épousant parce que à ce moment là vous
étiez un intellectuel qui n'avait pas
bonne presse dans la aux états unis donc
elle a pris un gros risque en vous
épousant je ne pense pas qu'elle se soit
jamais posé la question pour être
sincère je pense que les ris alors c'est
en deux semaines avait strictement
aucune importance
l'idée m'est venue à l'esprit
elle a dû se dire que les gens la
prendrai peut-être un peu plus de
sérieux qu'il n'avait fait par le passé
pourquoi dites vous qu elle était
condamnée dès sa naissance
écoutez merizzi
sa mère était atteinte d'une maladie
mentale était schizophrène szczepaniak
elle avait été interné à plusieurs
reprises pendant l'enfance de marilyn à
dasht qu'on peut se faire s'était
éclipsé
si donc l'a toujours été
les étrangers et en plus ces gens là
étaient des articles qu'elle n'était pas
légitime
c'était la responsabilité qui je vais
supporter le pcc qui selon lui a martelé
savoir qu'elle était battu sarine du
péché forte et que l'on qu'elle doit
porter elle-même un stigmate de ça et a
eu d'ailleurs un jour sa mère a essayé
de la tuer en l'étouffant os cos et
aujourd'hui cela veut dire qu'elle est
très lourd à porter c'était quelqu'un ce
serait selon eux re et c'est ce dont
elle n'a pas réussi à se débarrasser en
fin de compte
philippe lagouche pourri d'ailleurs dit
arthur mais là quelque chose très
bouleversant à propos de marilyn monroe
vous écrivez que c'était une femme qui
avait le don lorsqu'elle rentrait dans
une pièce où il y avait peut-être 30 ou
40 personnes de tout de suite sentir et
voir qui parmi ses trente ou quarante
personnes étaient comme l1 orphelin
oui ça c'est bouleversant et d'autre
part vous ajouté car au fond tout repose
n'est ce pas sur ce problème de son
orphelinat son abandon et c'est la seule
question que se pose cette catégorie
d'êtres humains c'est mémé vous et au
fond on a l'impression que marie n'a pas
cessé de demander au monde mais vous et
vous l'a demandé aussi mais cela n'a pas
suffi le fait que vous disiez wii n'a
pas suffi
mais sans jamais se fier
et c'est ça le problème avec ces gens là
par amos c'est à dire que cette forte
puissance et on ne peut pas accomplir ce
puits déversant quantité que ce soit ils
vont continuer à danser parce que c'est
quelque chose de très profondément ancré
dans leur âme que il ne pourra pas ne
peuvent pas être axée en fin de compte
il répète le méchant c'est à dire qu'ils
sont jetés et qu'ils vont tout perdre
donc si l'on essayait de des dissoudre
surf on le corrige et je peux vous dire
que c'est extrêmement difficile et dans
bien des cas je connais d'autres
comédiens ben ali sont dans ce cadre
qu'ils ont ce genre de caractère et
qu'il n'a jamais réussi à sortir ils ont
quand même réussi des toits ce bordel
une certaine sécurité que le rendait la
vie possible mais n'ont pas perdu ce que
ce trait de caractère
oui vous expliquer aussi la chute de
marc lynn parce que là je vous cite il
n'ya pas il n'y avait pas d'intérêt
tissent entre elle-même et la star
qu'elle était et vous ajoutez même elle
était marilyn et c'était cela qui était
en train de la tuer for what
elle attendait de son métier de
comédienne une certaine reste une
certaine rassurant et obtenez lorsque
vous êtes sur les places dans une
politique où ses scores avaié elle est
perdue je crois que c'était ça qu'elle
retirerait également sur l essayer de se
rassurer à tenir près de 100 une
assurance pour elle le pouvait avec
gaillac
tenez vous avez ici un grand acteur qui
étaient les planches
eh bien vous êtes vous-même de nouveau
c'est quelquefois dur oui entre willy
loman et le noyage heures et les
mélomanes
j'entre j'entre dans will ohman avec
beaucoup de joie et de plaisir parce que
je considère que c'est une immense pièce
et que c'est un formidable personnage et
autour ou s'il ya des personnages
absolument extraordinaire mais je dois
dire que je ne suis pas fâché de le
quitter à minuit parce que je ne
pourrais pas vivre très longtemps avec
lui
continuellement mais je les aime
beaucoup je reviens à marilyn il ya
aussi il ya la faute des journalistes
nous montrer très bien que les
journalistes ou autant il était couché
au pied de marilyn il était ba2
d'admiration ou de vénération
ou alors ils étaient d'une agressivité
épouvantable à son égard et puis c'est
la faute de l'amérique vous dit ceci
issue des années 40 et 50 marilyn était
la preuve que le sérieux et la sexualité
ne peuvent cohabiter dans la conscience
américaine qu'ils étaient antagonistes
je crois qu'il n'y a pas que ce soit
touché par cela je crois que ça se passe
également ailleurs c'est à dire la
france jusqu'aux années 60 mais halak
ont battu cela jusqu'à la fin quand vous
dites que c'est un peu universelle c'est
pas tout à fait vrai parce que je vais
vous donner une citation de votre livre
il était une autre citation il était
évident que le sexe et le sérieux ne
pouvaient cohabiter dans la même femme
et cette maladie typiquement américaine
n'était pep n'était pas près de
disparaître
typiquement américaine dit oui mais de
toutes les façons sur les maladies
américaine vous êtes plus que sévère
puisque à une autre formule fulgurante
qui dit qu'au fond la religion non
reconnu
amérique c'est l'autodestruction
effectivement je crois que c'est
justement le cas nous avons même une
pratiquement une industrie qui est
spécialisé l'adorent à l'opposé très dur
sur la civilisation américaine
par moments il ya des dents bien déclaré
que les choses vont très très loin
prenons par exemple les comédiens sont
que j'ai connu et qui ont remporté un
énorme succès et qui se sont
véritablement détruit cette chose
devrait pas citer le tournoi non mais la
liste est longue
nathan lane sont sales et raté ce sont
des gens qui ont eu un grand succès j'en
viens au miss fils vous avez écrit le
scénario les dialogues des misfits pour
être agréable marilyn je dirais même
pour la sauver et c'est là que vous
l'avez perdue c'est un cruel à exact
quand vous rappelez un échec pareil
c'est terrible pour est agréable écrire
un film pour quelqu'un pour dire je vais
la sauver et cesse et c'est justement
cette pièce qui vous à séparer à tout
jamais c'est donc un formidable échec
d'écrivains d'une certaine manière comme
ça oui ta propre
cela dit quelle somme pourrait encore
obtenir déroulera maastricht avec succès
démontré son talent parce que jusqu'à
présent je vais donner des sous et et
jouer déroulée tout à fait sérieux alors
on va la revoir dans un extrait des miss
fils c'est donc c'est un film de john
huston et on va la voir dans un dialogue
avec l'art gemmell vous allez voir c'est
absolument une scène déchirante qui
annonce on peut le dire la fin de
marilyn
ouais
[Musique]
oui parce que dormir et être un dieu qui
jouera père est inquiet l'intrigué pdg
d'emi
[Musique]
ok ok
oui mais gardent elles fin au chaos
rings et ong
c'est quand même inouï arthur miller de
penser que cet appel au secours
c'est vous qui l'avez écrit cccoi oui
mais vous dites aussi un peu plus loin
qu'au fond quand vous parlez de la pièce
que vous avez écrite peu après la mort
de marilyn monroe vous dites que au fond
c'est parce qu'on essaie de secourir les
gens comme ça qu'on échoue puisqu'on
veut les aider
et donc on dissimule leur échec et c'est
en dissimulant leur échec qu'on les fait
tomber un peu plus lent et il faut bien
suivre
winnik neuf médecins
donc je suis j'ai des impulsions et je
pense que je dois obéir à mezel notion
de cause on peut pas toujours prévoir et
dire ce qui va se produire et même très
rare bien sûr mais une dernière question
pardon votre livre traversée par à cette
culpabilité sa mauvaise conscience qui
doit habiter tout homme intelligent et
sur marilyn aujourd'hui vous êtes
débarrassé votre culpabilité
trente ans plus tard affirme ne ressens
pas de culpabilité à l'égard de marilyn
la cchit est offert grâce à moi j'ai co
le voir le jour l'impression
elle aurait pu éviter cette mort
prématurée
je ne sais pas comment cela dit j'ai
fait ce que je pouvais donc
vous oui je ne me sens pas prêt
personnel ou encore pas coupable et je
crois qu'il m'a combler pas de faire
plus que ce que j'ai fait bien d'autres
personnes doit se sont efforcés
d'intervenir de façon moins énergiques
les médecins mais n'y ont pas réussi à
l'or fin du troisième acte marie monroe
avec un autre petit portrait extrait
évidemment des mémoire d'arthur miller
portrait de marilyn encore je ne
comprenais pas comment marilyn était
arrivé à symboliser une sorte de
tonicité peut-être était simplement
qu'en la voyant les hommes devenaient
infidèles et les femmes folles de
jalousie etc alors les compromis
ordinaires de la vie paraît c'est
terriblement hypocrite et que son corps
seul était un blanc faisceau de vérité
elle savait qu'elle pouvait arriver dans
une soirée et faire le même effet qu'une
grenade détruire d'un sourire des
couples jusqu alors en bonne harmonie et
elle appréciait ce pouvoir bien qu'il
lui rappela cette vieille lugubre vérité
que rien ne dure dans la vie c'est ce
pouvoir là justement qu'il anéantirait
un jour voilà alors quatrième acte la
rencontre andré brink arthur miller sur
le plateau d' apostrophes monsieur
brink's voulez-vous venir s'il vous
plaît alors donc vous ne vous êtes
jamais rencontré soyez le bienvenu
voilà alors c'est curieux que vous ne
soyez jamais rencontré parce que c'est
aussi un autre aspect de votre livre
vous racontez que vous avez été nommé
président du pen club international qui
est l'organisation mondiale pour la
défense des écrivains et vous ne la
verra jamais rencontré bring
effectivement bon alors est ce que vous
connaissez le crois qu'il est trop jeune
présider opel c'était dans les années 60
et je ne pense pas car elle c'est m gla
vous étiez déjà écrivain
oui à l'époque j'avais une trentaine
d'années ah oui donc vous écriviez déjà
oui et vous accomp unis au plus haut
point club déjà pas de cette époque là
n'aura pas c'est parce qu en afrique
utilisant des peaux calepin club voulait
dire des vieux jean qui est ce qu'il dit
une fois les pièce d'arthur miller sont
jouées en afrique du sud
ah oui oui oui ah oui souvent presque
toujours oui et vous moi j'étais un fan
d'arthur miller depuis très très
longtemps
oui et je crois même que dans mon oeuvre
à moi j'ai beaucoup à lui dire merci
parce qu'il m'a beaucoup influencé je me
rappelle une situation très spécifiques
à propos de l'incident vichy oui
résidant à vichy qui y avait un essai
écrit par l'écrivain noirs sud-africains
justement sur cette pièce dans lequel il
décrivait des situations extrêmes
historiques ou l'oppresseur et l'opprimé
se rencontrent dans le silence où il n'y
a rien qu'on peut se dire ils se
regardent il n'ya que regard et le mode
on se servait cet écrivain noir sud
africain noël shabani s'étaient ils se
regardent dans une turbulence y lance
donc une phrase dont je me suis servi
pour le titre d'un de mes livres en
français un turbulent silence c'est ça
oui c'est exact mais bien et et vous
arthur miller est ce que vous connaissez
au moins de réputation andré brink hoya
c'est à dire son livre sur l'île
français mais
quarante pages de ce livre fascinant
oui c'était la seule forme que je
pouvais choisir dans ces circonstances
là parce qu'au milieu des années 80
pendant deux années
il ne m'arrivait pas décrit en seulement
parce que j'avais pas le temps de la
violence dans le pays et elle est
toujours tel qu' il est très difficile
de trouver le temps d'écrire donc à ce
moment là la seule façon d'écrire
c'était de prendre une heure par jour
peut-être de deux heures par jour
donc j'ai du jeu pouvait pas construire
grande architecture
je devais prendre une petite histoire a
ajouté un autre âge ajoute un peu
d'actualité ajouter quelque chose
d'autre mais les les livres d'histoire
de sorte en faire un roman d'essayer
d'en faire alors donc stock publie cette
semaine votre dernier roman état
d'urgence traduit de l'anglais par
michel courtois fourcy et qui raconte
une double histoire d'amour et à travers
laquelle vous vous posez la question est
il possible en afrique du sud pour à la
fois de vivre et d'écrire un run une
histoire d'amour qui ne fasse pas appel
à ce qui se passe à l'extérieur qui est
horrible en afrique du sud
c'est ça le sujet oui absolument et
c'est là pour moi un des des questions
en plus important dans la situation
actuelle en afrique du sud pas seulement
la question d'écrire une histoire
d'amour mais la question de vivre
intacte de vivre en isolation d'essayer
de vivre un amour qui ne soit pas
pénétré de l'extérieur et la situation
là bas est telle qu on ne peut jamais se
retirer du monde ne peut pas s'isoler
on se plonge toujours dans le monde et
il faut apprendre à vivre avec ça oui un
peu de réponses à cette question que je
posais lé nom est les deux fois non
puisque dans les deux histoires d'amour
que vous racontez la première c'est
l'histoire d'une jeune fille qui tombe
amoureuse dans un hôtel au bord de la
mer d'un homme qui est un proscrit et
l'histoire tragique va mal c'est remis
la deuxième histoire qui la plus longue
c'est les amours d'un professeur
d'université avec l'une de ses
étudiantes qui a trente ans de moins que
lui qui est qui devient son assistante
et là aussi c'est une histoire d'amour
qui ne peut pas échapper l'environnement
brutale de l'apartheid
oui mais hier quand même une troisième
réponse c'est que dans ces deux
histoires d'amour c'est l'échec à la fin
oui on peut pas réussir mais quand le
lecteur arrive à la fin de ses romans il
a quand même entre ses mains un roman
d'amour
il a quand même autre chose alors il
faut dire aussi qu'il ya une troisième
lecture d'autres moments c'est qu'à la
fois vous raconter comment l'écrivain
est en train d'écrire ce roman d'amour
se demande s'il ira jusqu'au bout et à
la fin et 10 n'ont finalement je
n'écrirai pas mais quand il dit ça le
roman est déjà écrit mais c'est
peut-être un autre que celui qui voulait
écrire oui alors je voudrais avoir la
réponse d'arthur miller à cette question
est ce que l'on peut écrire un roman
d'amour est ce que l'on peut vivre un
roman d'amour sans tenir compte d'une
violence extérieure
écoutez les écrivains comme ils ne
peuvent pas trouvé très intéressant dans
ce qu'il intégrait dossiers tels son
mandat le procédé va et brillant on
intègre le lecteur au problème
il y a même une troisième histoire
d'amour dans votre livre parce que
l'écrivain qui raconte se rappelle qu'en
1968 il était à paris pendant les
événements de mai il y a donc bientôt de
20 ans et qu'il a vécu une histoire
d'amour avec une antillaise
oui ça aussi c'est une histoire qui
change sa vie aussi
ah oui et bien sûr il ya une partie
autobiographique là dedans parce que moi
aussi je passais l'année de 68 à paris
je n'avais pas un amour avec une
antillaise m'a malheureusement pas mais
je vivais toute l'expérience de 68 à
paris et c'était justement là le
tournement le plus important de ma vie
c'était le cas oui parce que c'était
cette expérience là kim avait renvoyé en
afrique du sud
à ce moment là j'avais l'intention
d'explorer les possibilités de
m'installer
à paris en permanence et puis je me suis
rendu compte du fait que si l'écriture
m'était important il fallait le faire
sur place
ceux qui viennent de plus en plus
difficile bien entendu
alors il rencontre qui est tout à fait
curieuse on a parlé de willy loman que
joue françois périer l om n est votre
votre personnage le professeur s'appelle
philippe balland malade est l'héroïne
s'appelle mélissa par le man c'est
lothmann il ya un t2 différence habillez
vous remarquez c'est à huy lothmann le
man chez vous et lothmann chez brink's
oui il ya un petit jeu de danse et que
en afrique ans la première moitié de ce
moulin de ce nom là l'eau ou l'autre ça
veut dire sort et man ça veut dire donc
elle est la porte le sort de cet
homme-là atur miley est ce que les
est-ce que vous considérez que le
problème des noirs aux états unis est un
problème réglé maintenant au nord
absolument pas il n'est pas résolu
nieuwbourg de solutré km et à moitié des
voix genou mail nouvelle méthode
attaquer vos e mails va aggraver ce
qu'il ya dans la civilisation américaine
un talon d'achille décidera s'il y en a
un c'est bien lorsque l'on a essayé de
résoudre ce problème
les résultats ont été médiocres mais
dans la plupart des cas on ne s'en est
pas vraiment soucié mais est ce qu'il ya
des échanges entre les écrivains
blanc sud africain les écrivains
américains à propos de l'apartheid
est ce qu'il ya une lutte commune entre
les écrivains je n'ai pas l'impression
non il ya des contacts sur le plan
personnel entre quelques écrivains sud
africain et quelques écrivains
américains mais mais pas il n'y a pas
d'efforts communs nous mêmes pas les
écrivains noirs américains
selon ce que je sais il y à il ya
quelques uns parmi les écrivains noirs
américains qui ont d'influencé quelques
écrivains sud africain mais pour la
plupart les sud-africains la liste
africaine pour les écrivains noirs à
rester quelque chose à arthur miller
quand vous avez été président du pen
club et puis parce que vous êtes devenu
un écrivain universellement connu vous
avez souvent on a souvent utilisé votre
nom avec votre accord bien entendu pour
intervenir dans des histoires
déplaisante d'écrivains en b en prison'
et ça vous est souvent arrivé j'ai saisi
mon énergie morizet se servir du week
end pour essayer de venir en aide à
quelque sorte et qui faisait l'objet de
très sexy et à l'occasion soit donné de
bons résultats s'est dit navré de vous
reconnaître que emprisonné dans le
jourdain n'a jamais été aussi importants
écrivains et des journalistes ainsi que
les gens là sont les premiers atteints
j'aime attaquer bodji totalitaire
formation et porte-parole
ce sont des ce sont des voix que l'on
veut et réveillonner
nationale il faut pas s'illusionner le
problème est loin d'être résolu mais
enfin votre nom a servi par exemple à
sortir de prison
un écrivain qui allait devenir célèbre
pied du célèbre l'année dernière c'est
un prix nobel de littérature c'est
l'écrivain nigérian wole soyinka
rappelez nous raconter comme wahaha
connaissait pas son cas mischa sur loïc
il devait être emprisonné par l'une des
aperçus qu'en jouer d internet et on
accuser de préciser on a enfermé dans ce
cas on devait un des plus grands
londonien de données dans le cas je
demander d'intercéder on a mis en danger
précise que je le connais c'est toujours
pas donc j'adore qu'on le libère
est-ce que c'était le mari de la fille
d'une zone euro alors il m'a replacé il
m'a dit m'a dit que c'était
c'est quelque chose de très intenses que
bien de l'aventuré dire que le résultat
quelqu'un qui habite maurice et je pars
à bâle donc il est retourné en à
l'époque où franco il faut un peu
stupide ni la photographie livre on y
ajoute les observations on l'arrêté
prison et faute j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir progresser
un juge qui était un grand admirateur de
910 paillage heures il lui a dit bon
écoute et comme telle mais surtout
depuis sa visée par mettre les pieds
dans le pays et ne fait jamais de
remarques et jouera-t-il à l'automne et
c'est comme ça qu'a rahmane il arrive de
temps à table on puisse d'un moustique à
tous ou même un grand poster de moins
que de manière générale la situation est
catastrophique mais vous continuez à
agir en faveur des exploits et
d'ailleurs vous étaler en urss
il n'y a pas très longtemps tiré
oui mais par exemple si les plus graves
les acteurs dans le théâtre qui m'aiment
parce qu'il s'y disent c'est une
situation absolument alarmante
dernière question monsieur arthur miller
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous écrivez
maintenant les crimes que tu décris des
pièces de théâtre je viens de cornella
d'un film presque tout le monde qui
s'appelait presque tout le monde gagne
oui tu une comédie alors
jesse3 et vénère donc m'attends donc à
regret ce soir et nous allons travailler
et l'autre ajout il va travailler là
film qu'il doit donc j'espère que nous
allons d'ici la fin de la grève se voir
le tournée aux états unis dans le
massachussetts je reprends un peu ce que
disait philippe labro tout à l'heure il
me semble qu'avec la joueuse est devenu
plus je sais pas un peu plus
humoristique un peu plus détaché un peu
plus ironique non atteinte sérieuse ça
devient possible
non je me dis que si je fais une blague
et si je me trompe rien de vraiment
grave devait arriver un peu plus gai
très bien merci alors je signale que
dans livre de poche ce n'est pas grand
chose et quand même les miss fils
d'arthur miller dans la collection 10 18
et puis il y a le
le robert laffont publié deux sets et
publia très longtemps mais une nouvelle
édition du théâtre d'arthur miller avec
qu'ils étaient tous mes fils mort d'un
commis voyageur les sorcières de salem
je me souviens de de lundi a vu du pont
position robert laffont et puis alors un
mort d'un commis voyageur dans le texte
que je joue françois péry et ses
camarades ce genre club s'était adapté
par sinan nouvelle adaptation de jean
claude grumberg et qui publié dans la
collection très précieuse qui publie
beaucoup de pièces de théâtre
c'est à dire la collection actes sud
papiers donc si on veut le texte même
que joue françois périer et déjà calée
rade c'est toujours en vente dans les
théâtres n'osons voilà enfin on peut
l'acheter aussi bien chez ben voilà
alors à propos de l'afrique du sud
allam patton est mort cette semaine vous
avez dû bien le connaître je suppose ou
braisée oui
alors évidemment son chef-d'oeuvre sont
un best-seller mondial c'est pleure ô
pays bien-aimé
il est mort il avait 86 ans je crois
5085 voilà et puis à propos de l'afrique
du sud europe vient de publier un numéro
spécial consacré aux littératures
d'afrique du sud vient de paraître aussi
de pierre andré albertini qui a été en
prison en afrique du sud un en france
est en apartheid aux éditions gallimard
dans la collection vif du sujet c'est un
témoignage qui viennent paraître cette
semaine de ça c'est le film qui
s'appelle le cri de la liberté qui est
sur nos écrans actuellement
de john boyle est le cri de la liberté
aux éditions belfond et enfin ce roman
qui vient de sortir mais je n'ai pas lu
vous devez le connaître de voix c'est
les personnes connaissent et oui jamais
entendu parler vous connaissez pas les
greniers de la colère s'est traduit de
l'anglais par eric cerner ray c'est
aussi un aux éditions bernard coutaz à
l'europe parce que c'est le salon du
livre donc je vous engage vivement à
aller demain après demain et les jours
suivants au salon du livre il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de livres présenté
beaucoup d'auteurs qui qui s'ignorent
ouvrage alors des ouvrages qui se
rapporte vision à la profession du livre
tous les formats sas une annuel c'est
tous les livres au format de poche c'est
l'édition 1988 publié aux éditions du
cerf de la librairie c'est tous les
ouvrages qui sont publiés en édition de
poche et qui sont des disponibles oui le
livre augmente d'année en année ça
devient énorme bouquin à propos de
bibliothèques la véritable histoire de
la bibliothèque d'alexandrie par luciano
canfora aux éditions desjonquères c'est
une bonne histoire de cette fameuse
bibliothèque d'alexandrie alliera au
moment du salon du livre
denis colère j'apprends à lire avec le
journal c'est pour les enfants de 2 à 8
ans aux éditions raid ça peut rendre
service saas et par denise dupont
escarpit et claude lapointe et le guide
des illustrateurs du livre de jeunesse
français c'est publié aux éditions du
siècle de la librairie
et puis enfin par les éditions hatier
magnard nathan un livre des hommes de
lecteurs aux lecteurs c'est tout ce qui
ce qui concerne les la fabrication d'un
livre les métiers du livre donc par
gérard finel et daniel s'assied et puis
je vous signale qu'à poste dimanche soir
j'ai reçu la romancière grec margarita
carapa nous pour son roman le nom c'est
lundi soir
je crois pour le somnambule alors je
voudrais dire aussi à propos du minitel
vous faites donc que 36 15 apos et qu'il
y a toute une opération liés au salon du
livre c'est à dire que tous les soirs à
18h30
vous pouvez converser en direct avec
l'un des invités aujourd'hui c'était
hubert nyssen l'éditeur que j'ai
d'ailleurs reçu aussi la semaine
dernière alors demain soir à 16 avril
18h30 vous tapez vous tapotez et on
dirait que pour répondre à josé artur
qui vient de publier palomera ya que ça
qui m'intéresse
dimanche vous pourrez dialoguer en
direct avec françois nourissier pour en
avant calme et droit
lundi 18 avril avec le
des libraires yves simon pour le voyage
en magnifique mardi 19 avec annie ernaux
pour son livre une femme
elle a d'ailleurs été mon invité peu il
n'y a pas longtemps l'apostrophent et
mercredi 20 avril à 18h30 avec kanye et
mourad pour son best-seller de la
prennent la princesse morte voilà toutes
ces nouvelles sur le minitel donc je
vous engage tous à aller vous allez au
salon du livre monsieur luminaires
répondez-moi en france elle répondait
moi en français ah je sais pas ce moment
parce que j il me faut à travailler des
mains à hay demain mais ce serait bien
mais ça va être les meutes ainsi vous y
allez ça va être terrible pour bien je
vous remercie beaucoup d'être venu
spécialement pour cette émission merci
et merci aussi andré brink je suis ravi
que comme vous étiez de passage à paris
de pouvoir vous réunir avec avec arthur
miller bonsoir à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]